Let's say we're in the middle of parsing--I've written
new grammar for us, here on the left.
This one has a new nonterminal F--
just to make things interesting.
That is how we roll here, in programming languages.
So here's our grammar; it has 4 rewrite rules.
The input is: (int - int)
but we've only seen 2 of those tokens so far:
the (int) and the (minus).
One of the elements of chart[2] is:
(E --> E -), and Here We Are,
and we're looking for an (E) in the future--
and we started this in chart state[0].
I have written out, down here at the bottom,
five possible parse states.
Why don't you tell me which of these parse states
are going to be brought in by chart state[2],
by computing the closure?